from what I understand from Professor
Steve Furber part of the idea of
reducing description sets was to do more
stuff in software is am I going along
the right lines and you absolutely are
so the original risk principle reduced
instruction set computing is you should
never do something in hardware that you
can do in software because you keep the
hardware simple you keep the hardware
low power high efficiency you don't
waste time and effort and what's Jules
doing things that you could just do in
software well we put a few wrinkles on
that since we needed to put things in
hardware that were too complex to get
right in software so if it's really
really hard to guarantee that you've got
it correct probably the best place to do
that is the hardware
twelve years ago I came to work directly
from so I'm not one of the really early
boys until I knew several of the
founders myself they were friends and
still are but I only joined about 12
years ago at the point to which armed
was realizing they had take software a
whole bunch more seriously and we just
designed a multiprocessor CPU so we had
more than you know multi-core CPUs and
putting those together was introducing
some complexities in the software and
the Linux movement was really taking off
big time and so companies had to work
out who was going to write this who was
going to support it how do we encourage
other people to use this software once
we've sent it out there in the world and
it was it was really interesting tough
it's the right time to come in for that
and I worked very much in the junction
of software and hardware for many years
so my counterpart on the hardware side
you know he and I would have long
discussions about well we could do this
and why can't you just do that in
software and you know would always go
around in arguments like that my
understanding of that from a video point
of view is quite often it's easier to
have a hardware decoder to make sure
that you can play video smoothly is that
the sort of thing we're talking about
absolutely so we have a business in the
media processing group doing hardware
decode and hardware encode and the
answer is that we can build specialist
hardware to do it much more efficiently
than you could do it in software on a
CPU is 10 X 10 X this sort of now 10
times yeah 10 times so it's interesting
these things change all the time so when
when we were in the realm of MPEG and
CPUs got really good he looked like oh
it's not worth doing this anymore
but actually we then went from mpeg-2
h.264 and the marination or 2 6-4 280 BC
or HDR to 65 and we've traded
computational complexity for compression
ratios so now nobody would think of
doing a PVC and software it's just just
too hard and you would have very low
framerate or very high power or you
could just be horrible
how are you doing do it in a specialist
hardware block and you can guarantee you
know my hardware block will decode you a
frame of HEV C in exactly that number of
milliseconds come hell or high water so
you sometimes can't do that with
software so you can basically build in
assumptions because you know the
statistics you can and we do we work
absolutely to the worst case and we say
well what is the most complex frame we
could reasonably receive it's this okay
can we decode that in less than a frames
worth of time yes we can you know and we
prove it
it needs harder to do that what suffer
what is the most complicated video frame
look oh so all right digital video works
on compressing an image so you start
with if it's a 1080p frame you've got
2,000 pixels all of which has a color
which is expressible as 24 bits or
something and so that's quite a large
quantity of data if you were streaming
that data that would be a lot of
megabits per second completely
unfeasible just doesn't work so what we
do is we compress the video down and to
do that what we do is we observe that
from if you right take a picture and you
look at that how much of that picture
actually changes in a thirtieth of a
second so you'll I don't know what
you're looking at let's say you're
looking at my phone and my head and
shoulders yeah what if that is actually
changing well actually it's mainly my
mouth and I'm waving my fingers from
time to time you know the shirts not
changing the background behind me the
wall certainly isn't changing and so
what what we do in digital videos well I
was using a tripod if any to be honest
if you were using a tripod your videos
would be smaller what we do is we work
out which bits change work out which
bits don't change and often what happens
in video is the bits that change they
don't really change they move so you go
well that bit was there on this frame
and that bit is there on that frame and
so what we do is we encode the
difference by saying what it moved in
that direction that far and then really
by the time I got there the colors
slightly different so you you you
produce the deltas of the colors the
direction of the motion vector the
length of the motion vector and you
encode all of that down into a bunch of
numbers and you transmit those that's
how a digital video works and it's all
much of a muchness there are lots of
different compression standards but the
elements are the same which are that the
the eye doesn't see most of those
changes are three and it's much more
sensitive to certain types of things
than it is others so if it's brighter or
darker the eye is quite sensitive to
that if it subtly changes color the eye
is less sensitive to that and if he
moves the eye is incredibly sensitive to
that
so we trade those things off against
each other in different compression
standard so that's why if somebody sees
a glitch when they're watching a
streamed video you see some of the
screens stay where it is and maybe some
yeah it basically is a problem with
receiving data rules yeah so what
usually happens is you leave the
previous frame up and then replace it
with each bit of new data that you
receive so if the data stream gets
corrupted you usually get a bit of the
last frame um and this one on top of the
last one your eye doesn't like that
because if you particularly if you're
watching motion you think yes my hand
should move slowly across like that and
if my hangers by that you think that as
wrong and if there's any sort of sparkle
in it so you get sort of point a bright
white light in the middle of it and
things like that
I is incredibly sensitive to those sort
of areas so better compression standards
and better implementations have special
features in it to try and smooth out the
errors so basically these compression
standards are tailored for human eyes
I'm guessing yes if you talk to the guys
who invented as they talk about the
psychovisual understand understanding of
how the eye works and there's still
fundamental research going on into how
the eye and the ear because we do the
same sort of thing for audio is how the
brain
chili works if we knew how the brain
really worked as opposed to how we
thought it worked we could probably do a
better job of this there's plenty of
scope for getting this better in future
a lot of very clever scientists working
on it by subtracting these frames from
each other we can virtually shroud the
influence of daylight so we can even
eliminate cast shadows which would be
cast by direct sunlight